une rencontre inattendue les animaux
dans la ville ça n'est pas nouveau comme
ici en 2015 en californie avec le
confinement des incursions ont été
plusieurs fois observées aux quatre
coins de la planète
mais rien de neuf en réalité quand les
hommes abandonnent les villes les
animaux sauvages occupe la place ça
s'est déjà vu à tchernobyl par exemple
après l'évacuation de la zone irradiée
des landes et vautours y ont élu
domicile et plus surprenant encore sur
ces images exceptionnelles filmée par un
zoologiste ukrainien 4 l'eau dans l'une
des rues de la ville
mais les rues n'ont pas besoin d'être
désertés pour attirer les animaux des
bois depuis une trentaine d'années ces
incursions citadines sont de plus en
plus observé dargaud minda par exemple
en australie les deux sans trois
habitants de targon minda dans le
queensland ont eu la surprise d'être
réveillés par des centaines de nouveaux
voisins un peu particulier des
kangourous ainsi que des émeus affamés
et assoiffés à new delhi en inde
envahi par les macaques 6 à des singes
ici il y en a partout dans ce quartier
un millier au moins regarder la
bâillonne injustement atra ça qu'on en
italie où durant ce long hiver 2012
l'habitant a pu croiser en bas de chez
lui dès nous et ça aussi c'est du jamais
vu en louant ville affamés ils cherchent
de la nourriture chez les hommes mais il
n'est pas seul à quelques centaines de
mètres du village
voici un couple qui vagabonde
à berlin capitale des espaces verts il
ya des ratons laveurs des renards et
encore des loups en voici un au beau
milieu d'un jardin en 2016 l'image n'a
plus rien d'exceptionnel en allemagne
l'animal est aux portes les ville à
ville de zaouïah à l'ouest
une habitante a bien failli écraser cet
animal en rentrant le soir chez eux
un coup on pense à ce moment là à ne
surtout pas sortir de la voiture
à londres le renard empruntent les
transports en commun et joue les stars
lui il sait gaspard depuis deux ans et
demi
il rend régulièrement visite à cet
habitant sur le pas de sa porte et il va
même jusqu'à prendre la pose avec lui le
renard qui a aussi été vue à paris et
notamment aux buttes chaumont à rennes
c'est un cercle s'est égaré du jamais vu
dans la capitale bretonne
après une brève halte dans une cour
d'école sa course s'achève dans ce
square à deux pas d'un centre commercial
en californie des villes régulièrement
visité par des coyotes et donc aussi par
des ours depuis plusieurs semaines les
animaux sauvages en californie notamment
les ours n'hésite pas à se rapprocher
des zones habitées il manque d'eau ils
ont faim alors ils viennent en ville
pour trouver de la nourriture
à chaque fois c'est donc la sécheresse
l'attrait de la nourriture facile ou le
resserrement de leurs territoires qui
provoque ces incursions des
cohabitations contre nature qui sont
appelés à se répéter
[Musique]